also breaking tonight according to
foxnews.com a Biden commerce appointee
was a longtime business partner of
Hunter Biden now these are the kinds of
stories that the Biden Administration
would like censored by big Tech and
Twitter Etc but let's not forget that
this spring the White House was
attempting to set up a new Department of
government bureaucracy dedicated to
working with the social media Giants for
the purpose of policing information they
called it the disinformation governance
board remember this and they attempted
to appoint that far left lunatic singing
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
remember her Nina jacowicz to be the
board's disinformation Czar but after
widespread outrage jackowitz resigned
and the board was dissolved I'm sorry
jankowitz now she was also has since
registered as a foreign agent is now
gainfully employed by another country so
if you think this all seems incredibly
creepy and repressive you're not alone
and apparently it is even worse joining
us now with more Missouri Senator Josh
Hawley Senator tell us what you're
learning
um it sounds orwellian and chilling what
they wanted to set up
it is Sean and what they've done is
they've lied to us they have treated the
American people like fools you know the
Secretary of Homeland Security Alexander
Alejandro mayorcas rather came before
Congress and said oh the board never met
don't worry the board never met well it
turns out that's not true they had a
steering committee that was meeting four
months that was giving direction to
other agencies of the government we know
they tried to set up a meeting with
Twitter we know that they were meeting
with Facebook we know that they were
coordinating with the liberal dark money
groups we've got the emails now we're
dark money groups from the left these
advocacy groups are sending emails and
instructions memos to this
disinformation board and saying
basically here's what we think you ought
to do trying to influence their policy
it is the most unbelievable collusion
that you can imagine Sean and they lied
about all of it and now they've said oh
we're not doing it anymore that's not
true what they're doing now is they've
got all of these different agencies all
across DHS all across the FBI other
agencies of the government involved in
this so-called this information which is
really censorship Sean let me see if I
got this right and we're going to get
the facts they told you that they didn't
meet by May when in fact they started
having meetings as early as February and
you now have the evidence that in fact
they lied to you did they lie to you
under oath
yeah what exactly what happened was
secretary mayorkas came and said in
response to me Sean he said oh don't
worry don't worry the board it never met
well in fact the emails that they turned
over finally to me and Senator Grassley
showed that they had a steering
committee which was the executive
committee of the board meeting in
February they met on a weekly basis Sean
they were giving instructions to other
members of the government they were
communicating with liberal dark money
groups they were setting up meetings
with Facebook and Twitter so it's simply
not true that they weren't meeting or
doing anything of course they were this
Administration just lied about it over
and over again because Sean they don't
think they have to tell the truth they
don't believe in the First Amendment
what do we know about these dark money
groups that funneled millions of dollars
into Democratic advocacy groups what do
we know about it
well what we know is is that these
groups in one major group in particular
was actually sending memos to this
disinformation board apparently
advocating for policy sending it to them
remember the support supposedly doesn't
even exist yet and here you have the
liberal dark money groups know all about
it they are emailing policy memos to the
group to the disinformation board and
saying here's what you ought to do so
you have this collusion between the
liberal big money interest between big
Tech we know that the disinformation
board was setting up a special
arrangement with the big tech company so
that they could meet and coordinate
their censorship it's unbelievable stuff
Sean and this Administration has lied
about it at every turn they said they
disbanded this disinformation group and
you have evidence to the contrary that
that is not true they lied again
well here's what they're doing Sean in
fact we know from a federal court
lawsuit that is underway right now a
federal judge just ruled a few weeks ago
that the Department of Homeland Security
sits at the nerve center of federally
directed censorship that is a quote at
the nerve center of federally directed
censorship they have a whole operation
according to this judge according to the
facts presented in this case and it
involves DHS it involves the FBI it
involves multiple other agencies that
are using their power to track Americans
to conduct domestic censorship Sean I
think it's illegal I think it's
unconstitutional and we've got to get to
the bottom of it and stop it I think
this is the first time they will be held
in check and held accountable Senator
Hawley great job thanks for sharing that
with us it's important to know hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else